james paul congratulations you guys have
made it to the third and final round of
this competition now when you came here
we threw a little twisted damascus
challenge at you now we're sending you
back to your home for just to recreate
this iconic weapon from history you
ready to see it yeah sure all right
that weapon is
the darp sri gun chai
i've never seen anything like this i
can't even pronounce the name of this
thing
doobtree goontrobby what did he say
good luck gentlemen we'll see you in
four days
good luck man good luck
[Music]
day one i'm ready to get hammering
i'm gonna be using adcrv2 it's a very
good steel for impact and edge retention
and i believe the test that they're
gonna be putting this blade through is
gonna need a little bit of both this is
a big chunk of steel so it's gonna take
a minute to get the tip force down to
where i want it before i can start
drawing it out to the length
the thing i'm struggling with the most
is the weight of this entire blade i'm
having trouble keeping this thing
straight when i take it out of the forge
it's in the day one pretty happy with
the progress got it all drawn out ready
for a bath get started on this thing
first thing in the morning
[Music]
it's day one here at my shop in
fairfield connecticut and i'm going to
be making the darby street gun shy
for this challenge i'm going to be
making ladder pattern damascus because
it's really going to set me apart from
the competition this is 15 and 20 that's
the 1084.
i got to make sure there's no grease or
oil on them because that could affect
the forge weld after i get the steel
cleaned up i stack all the pieces up
together and do my initial weld
i'm feeling really good that the welds
have stock that's one of the most
difficult parts of the entire process
the next step is to grind in notches all
along the entire thing on both sides
and what that's going to do is expose
the layers of the damascus it's the end
of day one and i'm in pretty good shape
for the rest of the challenge
[Music]
pretty nervous today
we're gonna do this heat treat this
morning i'm only halfway through with
the time so hopefully if something does
happen i've got time to make another one
look at that
four-leaf clover right at my feet
i hope is a good sign
[Music]
i didn't feel any pings or pops
i'm happy
it's the last day and it's about time to
start etching the blade
this is the most magical moment of
making damascus because you get to
finally see what the pattern is going to
look like
still getting streaks though
i don't get it
it's just not at all what i wanted to
see there's a bunch of d-carb all over
the entire blade which means i didn't
grind deep enough and the etch is not
going to come out right
so i could either leave the d-carb and
the damascus won't be as good-looking or
i could grind into the blade a little
bit and risk making the blade too thin
i knew in order to save the pattern i
really had to just go back to the
grinder
and i think it's pretty good
this is the damascus i wanted to see i'm
still kind of concerned that the blade
is a little on the thinner side but
there's nothing i can do now
here comes the light from the end of the
tunnel so far i've got the blade done so
i'm gonna start working on a handle
i don't have long enough drill bits to
drill all the way into that handle so
i'm gonna have to carve out a channel
for that tang to sit in and make sure
the wood marries back together nicely
yeah baby
i made it a little of my own by adding
some fur from the land around my house i
think that's gonna add a little special
touch it is a little on the heavy side
but it's balanced perfectly it's very
wildable i'd say yeah all i could tell
you is grab it by the rabbit
all right bladesmiths welcome to the
kill test your dark street gunshots look
intimidating but are they deadly to find
that out i will take your weapon deliver
some killing blows in this ballistic
stomach
james you're up first you ready for this
there's nothing i can do to stop it all
right let's do it
to say i'm nervous right now is an
understatement at this point it's out of
my hands i just hope it can hold up
[Music]
all right james
first up that's a beast
it's very forward heavy so it definitely
feels like a chopper all the way through
now your handle here by adding this fur
around it i can't get a good grip on it
because it's so soft
now your edge
is sharp
overall sir
it will kill
thank you all right paul your turns are
you ready i'm ready let's do this
i built my blade to be very light it
definitely makes me nervous seeing the
ballistics dummy because i know there's
a lot of hard bones in there and i'm
definitely a little bit worried that
could bend even break in half you never
know what's going to happen
[Music]
all right paul first up i really
appreciate the damascus pattern that you
brought out here
now
the fact that i can hold the weapon out
extended like this shows just how light
this weapon is for its size and because
of that i can cut deeply into this
without using the weight just velocity
alone but after that striking skull it's
picked up a little bit of a bend overall
sir it'll kill thank you
all right gentlemen to test the strength
and overall construction of your blades
i'll be chopping into these pots
now remember this is not about what your
blades do to the targets but what the
targets can do to your blades
james you have first you ready let it
happen okay
this is a shoulder ripping monster
once you start this thing moving
stopping it is really rough on the
shoulders the fur around the middle here
it's a neat look but it's very slick
actually
and then your edge
is
still sharp you nailed it good job thank
you
all right paul you're up you ready yup
okay
i see the pots and i'm very worried i
feel like it could bend my blade even
more than it already is if something
goes wrong then i'm finished
[Music]
good job dude thanks
all right paul right off this weapon has
a feel that is excellent i can literally
use it with one hand
the edge
still sharp nicely done thank you
[Music]
all right bladesmiths to see how sharp
your weapons are we'll try to cut
through these pineapples
james here first you ready for this
let's go let's do this
nice nice
all right james
just a little off the top
your edge is sharp cuts cleanly all the
way through these pineapples
it will cut thank you all right paul
your turn ready yep
[Music]
there you go man gosh
all right paul
it is razor sharp just the thinness of
your metal here cuts through no
resistance if you get the pineapple
heads they're all still standing right
there it's very sharp and more
importantly
you have a cut thank
you
james paul you've both done an
incredible amount of work however there
can only be one forged and fire champion
in this competition and that champion is
paul congratulations you're the new
forging fire champion james please
surrender your gun chai
well i'm pretty happy we've made it this
far i don't think i can be too
disappointed in what i've done
considering how the weapon performed my
blade was just a little too heavy
congratulations great
you deserve it
it's been a really great experience i
did the best i could no matter what you
do in life there's going to be
challenges and you're not going to
always succeed
just get back up get back on the horse
paul congratulations you're the forge
and fire champion and that is the title
that comes with the check for ten
thousand dollars good job brother
thank you thank you
i just couldn't be happier this is like
gotta be the craziest thing that's ever
happened to me so far i mean i know i'm
only 19 but
i still can't believe it i'm the forge
and fire champion and it feels
incredible
you